Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, ich bin Podcaster und ich möchte heute Danke sagen.
Danke an alle Restintelligenten dieses Landes, die seit über einem Jahr unermüdlich verantwortungsvoll und mit klarer Haltung dafür sorgen, dass der Diskurs genau da bleibt, wo er hingehört, nämlich im Rahmen.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundneunzig vom was haben wir denn heute? Den vierundzwanzigsten äh April, zwanzig einundzwanzig
Ja und äh ich habe das Gefühl, es sind äh nicht alle ganz dicht.
Alter.
Was ist los? Was äh erlaube Schauspieler.
Wie erbärmlich, wie peinlich.
Genau. Hallo, ich bin's, äh ein überbezahlter Schauspieler, der sich keine Sorgen um die Zukunft machen muss in meinem exklusiven äh Einfamilienhaus,
mit Garten uns ja alles so schlimm.
Konnte gar nicht weggucken.
Ich konnte erst gar nicht hingucken. Ich hab's.
Ben Becker. Ben Becker am Set. Ja beschwert sich, dass er vom Plastiktellern essen muss und nicht drehen könnte. Vom Set aus seinem Clownsvagon.
Oh liefer's! Was erlaube,
aber und Ritchie Müller, ich meine, der hat wenigstens dann am Ende irgendwie vierundzwanzig Stunden oder so später eingesehen, dass das vielleicht eine absolute Unverfrorenheit war, was er da mit diesem Atmen aus Tüten gemacht hat, ne.
Also hätte es ja dann noch, sie hätte gesagt, ja also okay, das ist mir irgendwie nicht aufgefallen, dass das komplett asozial war.
Ulrike hat was was ist in die Gefahr?
Kanntest du die alle?
Die drei kenne ich, weil das Tatort äh ähm.
Ich gucke ja kein Tatort. Ich habe überhaupt mit dem mit der deutschen äh ich kenne ihn ein, ernsthaft.
Ist auch Tatortkommissar gewesen oder immer noch.
Habe ich mal gehört.
Und dieser, der, der, der den ganzen Quatsch initiiert hat, der hat der war auch Regisseur bereit bei drei Tatorten. Da gibt's auch.
Ich kenne die alle nicht. Das ist kein Witz.
Das ist ein Privileg, das ist ein Privileg. Wir gehen mit unserem Privilegien nicht an. So. Tu jetzt mal so, als würdest du die kennen. So und der der,
Der Typ, der das editiert hat, dieser Brüggemann.
Also es gibt ja jetzt so eine schöne Aufklärung, wo nur so beim NDR die, also die die Frage, die man sich ja eigentlich gestellt hat, ist.
Wie haben sie es geschafft, dreiundfünfzig Leute für diesen,
für die Aktion zu begeistern, ohne dass irgendeine von denen zwischendurch mal gesagt hat, so ey Leute, vielleicht, vielleicht ist das
komplett geschmackslos, geschmacklos und scheiße, was wir hier machen, ne. Und,
da äh eine Agentin, die beim NDR nicht namentlich benannt wird, hat halt irgendwie so gesagt so, ja, es wäre ja schon auffällig, wie viel Tatort da drin ist
ob die nicht vielleicht eine eine WhatsApp-Gruppe hätten oder so. Und ich glaube, genau das ist das, so ein Telegramkanal, der der Tatort äh Kommissarin oder sowas.
Also es ist äh ganz, also ich.
Das ist jetzt auch natürlich ein sehr sehr persönliche Sichtweise, aber ich komme komme mit deutscher Schauspielkunst ohnehin nicht klar. Also bei mir erzeugt das einfach,
Schmerzen und es hat in dem Moment auch,
gemerkt wieder, warum. Weil das einfach mit der Realitätswahrnehmung wenig zu tun hat. Die sind also wirklich da äh in so einem Spiel gefangen und äh da ist schon noch so eine dünne Wand zwischen ihnen und der Außenwelt. Und das,
hat sich da einfach sehr schön gezeigt, wie schnell man dann eben sich aus so einer Beklopptheit dann auch äh instrumentalisieren lassen kann. Das wurde ja dann auch,
wunderbar demonstriert, ne, indem einfach Querlinker, AfD und Hans-Georg Maaßen drauf angesprungen sind und äh gejubelt haben, wie sie doch jetzt hier irgendwie die Maßnahmen der Regierung kritis,
haben. Also wirklich eine Frechheit und ähm das ist halt einfach die die Gruppe der Leute, die überhaupt noch Schickungen hat, äh.
Überschaubar geworden.
Also ich ich muss dazu noch zwei, zwei, drei Sachen sagen. Also erstens, unter diesen Videos befindet sich eines von irgend so einem deutschen Schauspieler, den ich auch nicht kenne, der spezifisch.
Nur darüber spricht, ähm äh sich darüber lustig macht, was es bedeutet, Applaus von der falschen Seite zu bekommen.
Phase, da ist es ja alles, also alles ja wirklich hochgradig verstörend, was die da reden. Und in dieser Art redet er darüber so, wenn ich im Theater auftrete, dann darf rechts keiner sitzen, weil dann dann kommt der Applaus nicht von der falschen Seite. Aber wenn,
von der Bühne aus gesehen ist ja andersrum, also darf gar keiner mehr ins Scheiß, ne? Aber spezifisch.
Sich mit Applaus von der falschen Seite auseinandersetzen. Und das, bevor sie es überhaupt veröffentlicht haben, ja? Das ist das Erste. Das Zweite ist.
Jan, Josef Liefers, völlig durch. Im WDR-Interview,
Ja, die haben dir dann irgendwie zur aktuellen Stunde, haben sie den da äh und der setzt damit mit ungepflegten Haaren, im Bademantel, am Küchentisch oder so, ne, also weiß ich, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Designer äh Jackette, sieht aber aus wie ein Bademantel und ähm.
Sagt dann, also beschuldigt dann den Redakteur, der ihm Fragen stellt, dass, so wäre ihm ja zuletzt begegnet worden, was weiß ich, irgendwie in der DDR.
Und das ist der Jan Joseph Liefers, der unmittelbar nachdem er einen Scheiß redet, den kein Mensch,
hätte hören müssen, in die Nachrichtensendung des WDR geladen wird und und noch eine Stunde später bei drei nach neun sitzt, ja? Und dann irgendwie erzählt, er dürfte bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr sagen. Der heute in der Bild-Zeitung.
Das Titelblatt hat, ja? Und der der zieht hier irgendwelche DDR-Vergleiche. Sorry, der Typ hat alles, also der hat ja komplett die Bodenhaftung verloren
Und ich habe mich heute, ich habe lange auch wirklich so ein bisschen gerätselt, woran das liegt, ja und dann habe ich heute mal gefragt, so, ob eventuell, eventuell, nur eventuell der Verdacht,
ja? Das irgendeine kritische Koks-Infrastruktur hochgegangen ist,
und die deshalb jetzt irgendwie den Scheiß ziehen müssen, den du auf der Straße kaufen kannst, ne?
Hier Jean Peters vom Pain-Kollektiv hat mich dann darauf hingewiesen, dass hier vor ein paar Tagen irgendwo hundert Kilo äh Drogen ähm.
Du kein Scheiß. Und in Hamburg haben die auch vierzehn Kilo Koks hochgenommen. Die müssen jetzt einfach schlechten Shit ziehen.
Also ich versuche, ich ne, jetzt, ganz ehrlich, ich versuche hier die Entschuldigungen zu suchen, die Jan Josef Liefers nicht einfallen.
Der Typ spielt beim Tatort einen Rechtsmediziner.
Na ja, ich habe also der spielt nicht einen Sonder, der der ist einfach nur er selber, ne, also der ist, wenn du dir den anguckst, das kannst du jetzt von dem Burner, den er da im Tatort spielt, nicht unterscheiden. Das, also.
Der spielt ähm
im Münsteraner Tatort. Das ist, glaube ich, auch so wahrscheinlich sind das die beliebtesten Tatorte oder sagen wir die mit den höchsten Einschaltquoten zusammen mit dem
Axel Prahl,
ist ein sehr, sehr klamaukiger Tatort. Ähm der aber auch auf eine gewisse Weise Kultstatus hat. Axel Prahl ist so ein äh ja, so ein,
Sankt Pauli Fan äh Kommissar so mit ja, der sein Leben sehr einfach äh gestaltet und ähm der,
Jan Joseph Liefers ist
da halt äh dieser äh Gerichtsmediziner ein ein absolut arrogantes Arschloch, was er zu zu einer Selbstüberschätzung äh neigt und äh eine sehr smarte Assistenz hat, äh,
kleinwüchsig ist und die er immer als Alberich bezeichnet und so, ne, also so ein richtig also,
bis vor kurzem habe ich gedacht, dass er das spielen würde, aber er er ist das einfach, ja? Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diesen Beatlessong äh
aber ähm ja, das ist äh,
Also der Münsteraner Tatort hat tatsächlich äh sehr großes humoristisches Potential äh gehabt in letzter Zeit äh ist das hat das ein bisschen gelitten, weil die das auch übertrieben haben, ne? Also diese.
Diese Thiel und Burne-Nummer, die wurde in immer größere Extreme gezogen und das ist einfach nur noch,
einfach nur noch lächerlich. Vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich den Eindruck, dass das noch so ähm ja, eine unterhaltsames Salz in der Suppe war beim Tatort. Inzwischen ist das halt eine versalzene Suppe, der Monster war in der Tatort, kannst dir auch nicht mehr angucken.
Aber äh.
Ich bin beeindruckt von deiner äh Kulturkenntnis äh des des Deutschen ist. Ich gehe gerade nochmal diese Liste durch von diesen Videos, auf alles dicht machen.
Müller ist übrigens auch Tatortkommissar gewesen, glaube ich.
Ich lüge dich jetzt nicht an. Ich kenne keine einzige Person, von denen Heike Madschatz.
Heike Makatsch, du kennst Heike Makatsch. Stimmt, Makatsch.
Ja die die kenne ich, aber die ist da auch nicht mehr drauf.
Genau, die hat Anstand, die hatte.
Na ja, ich meine, man muss sich natürlich schon fragen,
wie wie kommst du da überhaupt erstmal hin? Ich meine, wenn sie jetzt zumindest schnell reagieren und so ein bisschen Einsicht äh generieren, ja, ne, aber jeder, der jetzt hier noch drauf ist, äh muss sich,
einfach was schämen. Aber ich kenne keine einzige dieser Personen und ehrlich gesagt
habe auch nicht das Gefühl, irgendwas verpasst zu haben jetzt und ähm ich hoffe, äh,
dass sie irgendwie noch zu retten sind. Dann schreiben sie ganz am Ende noch so, übrigens, fuck Nazis.
Ach ach ey komm, der Tim, der also was, was ich was das Fass, das also.
In einer normalen Welt, ja, würde man sagen, okay, alles klar,
Dreiundfünfzig Leute, kollektives Karriereende. Ähm was hat die da hingetrieben, ne? Könnte man noch ein Buch drüber schreiben, irgend so ein Psychoanalytiker oder so, ne. Oder ne, könnte man sagen, okay, krass.
Das Schlimme ist doch, dass das Tragische ist doch, dass die Bild-Zeitung, denen jetzt Recht gibt, ja, die Bild schreibt irgendwie, hier die Leute, die die Meinungsfreiheit von Jani Josef Liefers beschneiden wollen. Ähm die.
Herr Spahn will sich den.
Will sich mit denen treffen.
Ja, das ist doch alles, die haben doch alle, sorry, aber wir die ja.
Hast du dieses, hast du diese, mein Gott, hast du dieses Interview mit Ben Becker gesehen? Vor dem man das.
Also wirklich, ich rufe nein. Gehört ja auch dazu, aber der hat hier kein.
Nee, beim Bäcker wurde, ähm, ich glaube, am nächsten Tag, also dann von von Bild TV interviewt und ähm.
Also müssen jetzt mal neutral zu beschreiben. Also er führt dieses Interview geschminkt als Clown.
Vermutlich angetrunken aus einem Wohnwagen.
In Baden-Württemberg. Ja, also er beschreibt, dass er da am Set ist und seine schwerste Anklage, die er erhebt, ist, dass er sein Essen nicht auf Porzellan bekommt.
Ist die härteste Anklage, die er erhebt.
Und ähm.
Schnee.
Also du kannst es es ist absolut absolut absolut es ist.
Das Schöne ist, in der Krise merkst du wirklich, wer deine Freunde sind.
Na und vor allem ach so und die andere Anklage, die noch schwerwiegendere, die erklebt, die äh äh die erhebt aber die eben durch sein durch seine Präsenz am Set sage ich mal so ein bisschen an Schlagkraft verliert, ist das eher nicht drehen dürfte,
das wäre also wie wenn man einem Maler die Pinsel wegnimmt, ja? Und das ist aber natürlich schwierig, weil der halt da geschminkt am Set steht. Äh sodass da sage ich mal seinem eigenen Argument keinen Gefallen tut, so, ne?
Oh Gott.
Absolute Katastrophe und wie gesagt, steht jedem frei. Und ich finde das auch äh total gut, ja. Ich möchte auch eigentlich, dass das so viele wie möglich sehen, um sich da ihre Meinung zuzumachen. Und ähm.
Es ja zur Kunstfreiheit gehört eben leider auch und zur Meinungsfreiheit, dass äh das, was ihr tut, andere Leute scheiße finden. Und ganz schlimm, also das Tragische ist, dass das jetzt halt wirklich dann gewürdigt wird ähm,
Und ja und dass die halt von irgendwelchen Nazis wie ähm.
Von irgendwelchen Nazis da Applaus kriegen und in den Telegram-Gruppen jetzt rauf und runter gefeiert werden und sich quasi explizit vor der Veröffentlichung damit auseinandergesetzt haben, dass das passieren würde. Und also och, so geschma.
Regel eins, wenn du so eine Aktion machst und irgendwelche Videos veröffentlichst und du musst dem Ganzen ein dreitausend Zeichen langen Text voranstellen, wo du dich irgendwie erstmal erklärst,
ja wir lassen uns nicht in eine Ecke stellen mit rechten Verschwörungstheoretikern und Reichsbürgern dann dann läuft schon mal was falsch. Ich weiß ja jetzt nicht wann dieser,
dazugekommen ist, ob der da irgendwie von Anfang an stand oder äh ob sie das dann später reingeschoben haben, dann müsste man jetzt mal hier ins Archiv äh gucken
aber das ist doch einfach mal, ey Leute wirklich, haltet euch einfach raus. Also das ist einfach die die Prominenten sind auch ehrlich gesagt,
auch ein ein weiterer Fail in dieser Gesellschaft, in dieser Krise. Da ist echt nicht viel gekommen. Natürlich es gibt Ausnahmen, gibt erfreuliche Ausnahmen, ähm,
Ja, wie Bimmermann, der auch, glaube ich, die einzig richtige äh Reaktion darauf gezeigt hat und einfach gesagt hat, so das einzige Video, was man sich angucken muss, ist hier irgendwie die Dokumentation,
die äh Coronastation in der äh Charité und irgendwie, glaube ich, gleich die Domain mit Punkt com. Ich weiß nicht, wer sich das hat einfallen lassen, die dann darauf äh verweist, dass
Okay, da sind dann so Spitzen, ne, zeigen aber zumindest, dass es noch so ein bisschen ähm ja, dass es so eine Gruppe gibt. Also ich äh appelliere wirklich an die Gruppe der Restintelligenz, ne. Bleibt einfach mal klar.
Irgendwie auch noch umkippt so, dann äh ist überhaupt nichts mehr zu retten. Wir müssen jetzt auch wirklich die Fassung bewahren, ist wichtig
und ähm ja, die Schauspielerzunft in Deutschland, die hilft auf jeden Fall nicht.
Der ich bin hier gerade auf dieser Seite, der mit der äh mit dem Applaus von rechts äh Ding ist. Jens kannte ich vorher auch nicht, aber äh ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch für so eine lustige, lustigen Beitrag. Ähm,
Ja, man kann also.
Das Schlimme ist ja also diejenigen, die sich davon verabschieden äh und davon lossagen, denen das muss man natürlich anerkennen, das ist äh Heike Makatsch, Merit Becker, Richie Müller, nach meiner Kenntnis bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, ähm die sich davon,
distanziert haben und sich dort haben entfernen lassen.
Ich finde auch das Video von Ulrike dort nicht mehr interessant ist.
Natürlich dann auch mit welcher mit welcher Begründung und so man das tut. Und ähm das sind natürlich dann auch streckenweise sehr selbst
sehr selbstmitleidige und sehr selbst dienliche Begründung, mit denen die Leute das da gemacht haben, mitunter. Ja und ähm,
Ja, was eigentlich notwendig wäre, wäre halt mal auch also zu benennen, was hält's ja auch an dieser NDR, die Sache, der die mal auf den Grund gegangen sind, so, wie kriegst du.
Dreiundfünfzig so Leute dazu, so ein
zu machen, ohne dass irgendjemand mal sagt so, ey, vielleicht ist das eine schlechte Idee. Und was was man bis jetzt halt hört, ist, äh dass äh dass Ritchie Müller hat, das äh glaube ich gesagt, dass da halt auch Drehbücher verteilt wurden. Also die konnten sich ihre Rollen sogar aussuchen
Ja? Was das jetzt irgendwie besser oder schlechter macht, das äh dass das.
Wird dann gar nicht selber gedacht. Sondern da hat eine Agentur äh was entworfen, ja und die Schauspieler tun halt das, was sie halt tun. Sie spielen eine Rolle.
Agentur wohl nicht, also dass das scheint wohl primär tatsächlich auf diesen Dietrich Brüggemann und den Jan-Josef Liefers zurückzugehen. Was ist was ist bisher äh was da bisher äh äh öffentlich gemacht wird? Die Agentur spezifisch nicht.
Aber da ist doch für so eine Agentur die Rede.
Nein nein eine eine Agentur, also was hier in dem NDR-Bericht ähm zitiert wird, ist eine Agentin, die sagt, ähm also hier.
Ich zitiere mal kurz aus dem NDR Text. Die Künstleragentur, die normalerweise die Kreativen und sozialen Engagements der Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler koordinieren, waren offenbar nicht eingebunden
Entsprechend groß ist bei vielen der Ärger. Ich habe allen gesagt, dass das eine saublöde Idee ist, erzählt eine Agentin in den Hintergrund gegenüber Zapp
Von den Plänen, wissen sie sie schon seit Anfang März. Die Aktion habe sich ausgehend von einer Handvoll Leuten in konzentrischen Kreisen über persönliche Netzwerke verbreitet. Erstaunlich sei die Dichte der Tatortkommissare,
gerade so als hätten die eine eigene WhatsApp-Gruppe, spottet die Agentin.
Okay, aber da ist so eine so eine so eine Agentur Wunder am Werk. Da heißt die, die irgendwie.
Ja, okay, dann habe ich.
Das ist wohl dieser Typ, ja Wunder, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall Scheißidee und äh Leute,
geht wieder zurück in eure kleinen Fernseh äh Kammern und glaubt nicht, dass ihr irgendwie groß was beizutragen habt. Ich meine, man merkt dann auch, wie auch gleich, es gibt da noch ein paar Leute, die irgendwie klar kommen hier so. Nora Tschirner habe ich einen Kommentar.
Die hat sich da korrekt geäußert.
Ulmen auch.
Worauf man auch drauf äh verweisen sollte, ist dieses Interview von einem menschlich auch nicht kannte vorher, aber gerne ideal kennenlernen möchte jetzt. Ullrich Matthes.
Ähm der äh bei 3Sat Kulturzeit da ein längeres Interview zu zu gegeben hat und meiner Meinung nach alles dazu sagt, was man dazu sagen äh,
vernichtendes äh Urteil und klares Statement. Also nicht, dass es jetzt hier heißt, so
wir scheren alle Schauspieler über einen Kamm, gibt genug Schauspieler, die irgendwie auch Grips in der Birne haben und ähm Schauspieler allein ist halt jetzt erstmal noch keine Qualität äh,
für euch gilt, wie, glaube ich, für alle, die so halbwegs in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, ja? Dadurch, dass ihr dieses prominenten,
gesetzt habt bei euch. Ja, das mag bei manchen größer sein, bei anderen kleiner sein, aber Bekanntheit, Prominenz,
das sind alles Dinge, die dazu führen, dass Leute einem vielleicht mehr Aufmerksamkeit geben
als es manchmal angemessen ist und dementsprechend steigt mit der eigenen Prominenz auch die eigene Verantwortung. Und der hat man verdammt nochmal
gerecht zu werden. Wenn man so das Maul aufmacht, dann sollte man auch entsprechend vorher darüber nachgedacht haben. Und das hat hier definitiv nicht stattgefunden.
Und da muss man noch dazu sagen, bevor das jetzt auch wieder losgeht, ne, also äh.
Wenn die jetzt irgendwie das dürfte man nicht mehr sagen oder so, ne. Es wird halt bewertet nicht der Kern eurer Aussage, sondern auch die Qualität. Und äh die ist halt hier nicht vorhanden. Es wäre ja durchaus, ne, also es wäre ein Leichtes gewesen,
für die. Zum Beispiel eine wohlformulierte.
Und gut erklärte und bist durch Wissenschaftlerinnen, Gebäckte Aussage, zum Beispiel zu dieser Frage der äh Ausgangssperre nach zweiundzwanzig Uhr zu formulieren. Und daran eine Kritik zu formulieren. Es wäre übrigens,
muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen. Ähm sehr in meinem Sinne auch gewesen, hier die Situation der Kultur.
Mal qualifiziert aufzuzeigen, denn es ist ja richtig, dass ähm im Prinzip die die Kultur,
Die Hauptleitragende der Coronamaßnahmen ist,
und das ist ja ein ein Zustand, den man einfach auch mal beschreiben kann, in dem und auch eine Frage ist, die man sich mal stellen kann. Ist das eigentlich,
in Ordnung, wenn wir in unserer Gesellschaft diese Einschränkungen, die zum Schutz vor der Krankheit erlassen werden, so ungleich verteilt haben.
Und das ist etwas, was man supergut mit mit dieser Gruppe hätte formulieren können
und die hätten sich auch mal super gut ohne sich einen Zacken aus der Krone zu brechen. Solidarisieren können mit der äh Pflege und Medizinbranche, die zu Hungerlöhnen hier die ähm
die äh die die Corona,
erkranken, die Covid Erkranken pflegt bis zur Erschöpfung, ja? Und dass wir alles möglich gewesen, das das ist eine Position, die es gibt und die man sehr gut vertreten kann und die eine sehr starke ähm,
und ähm fundierte Kritik an den,
gesellschaftlichen Missständen ausdrücken kann. Und die Chance, mit dreiundfünfzig Deutschen Prominenten zu verkacken, mit Anlauf und absichtlich und wissentlich äh und dann noch irgendwie so ein DDR-Gefahr da loszuwerden, das ist.
Da da wirklich, da habe ich also habe ich kein Mitleid, also eigentlich noch,
Wirklich und dann noch vom Gesundheitsminister dafür eingeladen zu werden. Und jetzt durch die Talkshows zu tingeln. Das ist das ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Ähnlich übrigens, ich habe da gestern auch zugetwittert. Nächste Woche sitzt der Liefers dann bei Anne Will und Lanz.
Diskutiert
Karl Lauterbach oder Christian Drosten und Heribert Brannte sitzt daneben und schreit dazwischen und alle happy. Und genauso wird das kommen. Und Heribert Brannte ist übrigens auch eine schwere Enttäuschung, weil der auch
mit seiner äh mit seiner Reichweite und seiner über mit und seinem seinem Status und seiner äh seiner Argumentationsfähigkeiten sehr viel klügeres Argument vortragen könnte, als das, was er tut.
Und dann da irgendwie nur so ein dieses Grundrechtsgelaber, statt ne, muss man wirklich sagen, ne? Statt das mal vernünftig zu untermauern,
zu sagen, das und das muss besser sein, das und
das ist ein Problem und so geht es, aber nein, es ist immer die setzen sich da hin und sagen, man dürfte irgendwas nicht mehr sagen und sie sie tragen in keiner Form
konstruktiv dazu bei, dass wir aus unserem hochinzidenz durch Seuchungsland das alles verkackt irgendwie in eine bessere Position kommen.
So viele kluge, wichtige Positionen vertreten können und sie haben sich für so einen Scheiß entschieden.
Wie schreibt ihr die ganze Tür so schön? Bewegende Geste, Bürgerklatschen für reiche, privilegierte Schauspieler, die während der Corona-Pandemie am meisten leiden mussten.
Oh je.
Slow Clap, meine Freunde. Slow Clab, kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass hier die die These mit der mit der äh mit den Qualitätsschwankungen in den in den in der Suchtmittelversorgung noch die beste Erklärung dafür ist.
Ja, danke, dass wir jetzt die ersten zwanzig Minuten unserer kostbaren Zeit hier jetzt auch so einen Scheiß wiederverwenden müssen, aber sonst hätten wir uns jetzt irgendwie auch echt nicht so richtig in Rage und Stimmung reden können, insofern danke vielleicht auch.
Danke. Wir müssen wirklich jetzt mal danke sagen.
Okay, da haben wir zwei kurze Sachen zu empfehlen. Und zwar äh zwei Podcasts. Ähm einmal
ich äh zu Gast bei Malik FM. Ähm ich habe ja äh wie vielen auffällt
rede ich selten irgendwie privat, öffentlich und konzentriere mich hier eher auf,
Das politische Geschehen, das hat der Malik Aziz kritisiert und wollte sich mal privat ein bisschen mit mir unterhalten, haben wir gemacht. Äh, ich habe ja Sendung, Episoden Nummer dreiundzwanzig, ja, das.
Ja, also und.
Genau, wer sich das anhören möchte, dreieinhalb Stunden kann das da machen, wenn ich dann nicht.
Ist es nicht schön, dass du deine dass du mal deine Meinung wirklich auch frei verbreiten darfst?
Ja. Das, da habe ich alles gesagt, was ich bei Tim nicht sagen darf. Und.
Es muss auch Grenzen haben, ja, auch Freiheit hat Grenzen.
Genau und dann haben wir, genau, also Link ist in den Ansatz unter Malek Punkt FM. Und dann gibt's noch ein Podcast Serie, die veröffentlicht wurde und zwar der Mann in Merkels Rechner von Hakan Tanry Verde
ich habe immer Tanri, Verdi hier immer gesagt. Ich habe in der in dem Podcast spricht der seinen Namen selber aus, ne, hört man natürlich,
wie man ihn ausspricht ähm und Florian Vlade ähm der Mann in Merkels Rechner und zwar setzen die sich damit ähm,
Also das haben wir hier im Logbuch auch immer diskutiert, nämlich diesen Angriff im Frühjahr zwanzig fünfzehn auf den deutschen Bundestag.
Und die ähm ja russische Hackergruppe dahinter und die dann auch hier dieses,
Waffenexportkontrollgremium in Den Haag angreifen wollten und so weiter und dass sie am Ende waren ja die Ermittlerinnen sogar in der Lage, da eine Einzelperson heraus zu identifizieren.
Und äh wir haben das hier über die Jahre eben auch immer berichtet und diese Podcast-Serie setzt sich damit,
auseinander. Wie das also über die Jahre auch zusammengetragen wurde, wie die also, woher die die Beweise haben, welche ähm.
Maßnahmen da von den Niederländern angestrengt wurden und so weiter. Ähm ist auf jeden Fall äh sehr interessant aufgearbeitet und äh kann man sich gut mal anhören.
Gut, das äh bringt uns dann zum Feedback.
Dann äh muss ich einmal ganz kurz, genau, ich hatte letzte Woche oder letzten Sendung diesen random Check-In für die Luka-App der falschen Person zugeordnet und wenn ich das richtig sehe, war das.
Mann, wie spricht man das denn aus?
Was? Mähnen Wolf.
Na ja, ganz genau. Genau nicht, ich hätte jetzt den Twitter äh Account. Genau, fertig, danke.
Ganz einfach.
Okay, so. Also sorry, darf ich falsch falsch auf Twitter geschaut, wer was genau gebaut hat?
Dann haben wir relativ viel äh Feedback bekommen zu unserer Frage mit warum läuft eigentlich das mit der Digitalisierung so schief in Deutschland? Also was ist so der eigentliche Grund?
Glaube, das wird sich auch nicht äh final klären lassen in dieser Sendung, aber wir haben Feedback
bekommen, per Mail und auch in den Kommentaren und auch über andere Kanäle. Äh auch viele Gesprächsangebote, vielen Dank äh dafür, weil das jetzt nicht zu sehr
Tiefen, aber vielleicht trotzdem mal so ein, zwei Anregungen aus dem Feedback hier wiedergeben, weil da ein paar ganz interessante,
Gedanken drin sind, die äh sicherlich wert sind, dass man darüber noch ein bisschen weiter nachdenkt.
Wir beginnen mit äh Susanne, die uns per Mail äh geschrieben hat. Hallo ihr zwei,
musste ich schon wieder schmunzeln, okay, schmunzelle häufiger, aber nicht jeder Schmunzel ist ein Kommentar wert. Diese ganze Gemengelage mit den Bundesländern, der Luca-App und den Ausschreibungen klingt ehrlich gesagt für jemanden, der schon in den Behörden gearbeitet hat, gar nicht besonders neu.
Prinzipiell ist doch klar, was da gerade passiert. Es wird Geld auf ein Problem geworfen in der Hoffnung, es verschwindet. Und die Leute, die werfen, sind weder besonders klug, noch findig,
weitsichtig. Klar wäre es besser gewesen, wenn man das Ganze über eine Ausschreibung gemacht hätte,
Aber das hätte am Outcam nix geändert. Es hätte nur erstmal besser ausgesehen. Die verantwortlichen Damen und Herren haben sich diesbezüglich nicht sehr klug verhalten, denn eigentlich macht man es so,
aus welchem Grund auch immer schon einen Favoriten hat, den man gerne als Gewinner einer Ausschreibung sehen würde,
zuerst die Marktanalyse, damit man sehen kann, was es alles noch so gibt und inwiefern man diskriminierungsfaktoren beziehungsweise Alleinstellungsmerkmale finden kann, die den Favoriten begünstigen.
Dann eine entsprechende Ausschreibung verfassen, die diese Faktoren und Merkmale einfordert. Und falls dann tatsächlich noch mehrere Nebenbuhler übrigbleiben, den Favoriten, lebst zwei Toreren angeboten, einreichen und zurücklehnen.
Ehrlich, der Grund für die Existenz.
Ausschreibungsverfahrens ist ja äh ehren und richtig, aber das Verfahren macht eigentlich nur zwei Dinge. Erstens, Bürokratie erhöhen und zweitens die Favorisierung von minimalistischem billigen Schrott
siehe, Bär, denn wenn man eine Ausschreibung tatsächlich normal durchführt, muss man letztendlich das günstige Angebot nehmen und das ist oft eben auch nicht zielführend,
eigentlich nur sagen, das Problem ist nicht die fehlende Ausschreibung oder die Verschwendung von Geld. Tatsächlich glaube ich, bekommen wir gerade die Quittung für ein ganzes Sammelsurium von Missständen, die sich vor allem in den Behörden Bundesinstitution und auch im akademischen Sektor angehäuft haben,
Zusammengefasst lässt sich das am besten mit diversifizierter Inkompetenz in Schlüsselpositionen beschreiben. Denn genau das ist doch letztendlich die Ursache vieler Fehlentscheidungen, die wir gerade sehen, egal wie sich diese Inkompetenz manifestiert, Korruption
Unverständnis, Verblindung, Public Geilheit, Überforderung, Überarbeitung und so weiter. Abgesehen von den offensichtlichen Ursachen möchte ich hier noch kurz zwei nennen.
Zum einen die Personalpolitik in den Behörden und Instituten. Diese begünstigt auch verschiedene Arten und Weisen, dass Menschen mit einer bestimmten Konstellation von Eigenschaft,
dort oftmals unbefristet arbeiten. Es fehlt an Diversität, denn die würde resilient gegen Krisen machen und mehr Kreativität fördern.
Außerdem fehlt es am Willen beziehungsweise der Möglichkeit, unpassende Mitarbeiter auch wieder zu entfernen.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die Lichtblicke in dieser Krise vermutlich genau von den Mitarbeitern stammen, die eine Ausnahme bilden oder die gerade befristet auf der Durchreise in den Institutionen arbeiten.
Der zweite Punkt hat etwas mit den Verschwörungsmythen und vermeintlichen Experten zu tun. Es ist ja schon schlimm genug, dass sich Nichtwissenschaftler oder gebietsfremde Wissenschaftler als gleichwertige Experten,
in die akademischen Diskussionen einmischen und Gehör finden. Aber diese Art von unqualifizierten Beiträgen kommt mitunter auch von Leuten vom Fach.
Beispielsweise einem Virologen, was ungleich viel beängstigender ist,
möchte ich kurz auf etwas hinweisen, was ich in meiner akademischen Laufbahn schon oft als bizarre angesehen habe. Vorausgesetzt, man hat finanzielle Mittel und Zeit,
jeder Depp einen Doktortitel bekommen. Es ist wirklich einfacher, einen Doktortitel zu bekommen, als zum Beispiel eine Ausbildung erfolgreich abzuschließen.
Durch eine Ausbildung kann man zumindest durchrasseln, durch eine Promotion eher nicht. Da müsste man schon selbst aufgeben. Der Grund ist, dass Doktoranden einerseits die Billiglohnsklaven der Wissenschaft sind und andererseits auch als quantitativer Bewertungsmaßstab für Arbeitsgruppen fungieren.
Man stellt sie also auch ein, damit man eine billige Arbeitskraft hat und man boxt sie letztendlich durch bis zum Anschluss, damit die eigene Quote stimmt. Und dieses durchboxen geht auch so weit,
andere, die komplette Arbeit übernehmen
und auch Publikationen verzichten, weil ein Fail inakzeptabel ist. Tja und dann schließt sich der Kreis, weil so jemand vielleicht in einer Behörde landet und nach einer Talkshow ihre seine oder ihre persönliche Meinung zum Besten gibt, genug ausgekotzt. Macht weiter so, Susanne
Das war lang, aber interessant, ein etwas äh kürzerer Kommentar noch von äh AD. Zu äh demselben Thema.
In der Überlegung, warum Deutschland in Bezug auf Computing in der öffentlichen Verwaltung dysfunktional ist, wäre natürlich ein guter Überblick über die Vergleichsländer nötig, der mir fehlt.
Wird vermutlich immer ein Beispiel finden, wo etwas bereits umgesetzt wurde, aber die Frage ist eher, wie sieht das Feld aus, insbesondere Länder oder Landesteile mit ähnlichen Bedingungen?
Dann ist die Frage, wie sehr passt, eine woanders bereits erfolgte Umsetzung zu den eigenen Ansprüchen
Eine Lösung, die schon vor Jahren umgesetzt wurde, aber alles verbaut hat, was man auch an gegenwärtigen deutschen Umsetzungsplänen kritisieren würde, ist dann nur noch ein Ausweis davon, dass man dort schneller war
Also ich möchte nicht ganz ausschließen, dass ein Teil der Antwort hier auf einen Blick in den Spiegel hinausläuft,
dort, wo Computing in den Verwaltungen schon lange Einzug gehalten hat, die Leute weniger Sorgen, weniger Ansprüche haben an den Schutz bestimmter Rechte, an nicht Kommerzialität, an Offenheit und Transparenz,
Wir sind eben selbst eine Art Bedenkenträger. Die Realität im Internet scheint mir dagegen zu sein, dass etwa die allermeisten Plattformen, die groß geworden sind, all diese Ansprüche nicht erfüllen.
Auch ein guter Punkt. Gut, ähm dann hatten wir noch einen Kommentar,
zu der Meldung äh rund um die Energe S Covid äh,
also die App, die quasi wie die Corona-Warn-App, ja, auf diesem basiert, aber von Apple das letzte Update zurückgewiesen wurde.
Genau und da war ja unsere Frage, wie das was die genau gemacht haben, dass Apple das zurückweist, weil es ja nur kurz zur Erinnerung, weil's ja darum ging, dass Apple das zurückgewiesen hat, weil sie gesagt haben, ey jetzt habt ihr hier Location Tracking drin
ne? Und das, das war, wir haben's nicht ganz verstanden, was die jetzt gemacht haben, dass das, dass das als Location-Tracking interpretiert wurde.
Genau, dazu gab's dann Ordern äh Kommentar,
Das Check-In Feature war dort schon seit letztem Sommer implementiert die QR-Codes hierfür werden zentral auf einer Webseite des NHS erzeugt und mit konkreten Orten verknüpft.
Bislang wurden die Check-Ins eines Nutzers jedoch nur lokal gegen eine Liste infizierter Locations, die vom Backendkommen abgeglichen,
Nutzer gegebenenfalls aufgefordert, sich zu isolieren oder testen zu lassen. Neu sollte jetzt hinzukommen,
nach einem positiven Testergebnis optional die Check-Ins der vergangenen Tage hochgeladen werden können, um eine Clustererkennung zu erleichtern.
Bisher wird dieser Prozess von Contact Tracern manuell gemacht. Bei der deutschen App sollte der Upload mit Einschränkungen kein Problem sein, da es keine zentrale Datenbank aller kurzen zugehöriger Locations gibt.
Also hier wurde quasi im Prozess die ähm Methodik äh so.
Geändert, dass eben genau dieses zentrale Einsammeln von Bewegungsdaten möglich gewesen wäre. Und das haben Apple und Google dann äh entsprechend sanktioniert.
Ableite, die schauen sich das schon sehr genau an, was bei den Apps einzeln passiert. Das ist schon ein anderer Prozess, als das jetzt so normale äh Apps äh sehen.
Ja. Also auch vielen Dank für die,
Erklärung und dann ist jetzt über das Wochenende das geschehen, worauf wir seit, ja, Monaten gewartet haben, die,
Corona-Warn-App hat eine Check-In-Funktionalität bekommen. Kleine Erinnerungen, ich habe das nochmal rausgesucht. Ich habe's ja glaube im Oktober.
Ähm zum ersten Mal gefordert und ähm
gleichzeitig oder kurz davor oder kurz danach, kriege ich gerade nicht mehr hin, wurde das eben als ähm schon,
auch wirklich mal sauber ausformuliert von so Leuten wie und einigen anderen.
Möchte einfach mal sagen, großen Namen der IT und Privacy.
Forschung, ja, also mit ähm Universitärem, akademischen Hintergrund wurde eben dieses Crowd-Notifyer formuliert.
Ähm jetzt ist natürlich äh oder jetzt ist in die Corona-Warn-App ein System eingezogen, was sehr,
sehr nah an ist. Ich will die Details jetzt gar nicht äh diskutieren. Ähm was da die Unterschiede sind, sondern einfach mal sagen, okay, was macht die Corona-Warn-App? Du kannst in der App jetzt ein,
QR-Code generieren
Sagst du, ich möchte ein Event machen, was weiß ich, privates Event oder äh die geben dir da auch eine Auswahl. Was sehr schön ist, weil sie in der Auswahl auch schon direkt darauf abzielen, dass du im Prinzip
kleine Events anlegst, ja? Nicht so etwas wie,
einen Zoo, was halt epidemiologisch komplett unsinnig ist, ne? Also sie leiten da so äh lenken da so ein bisschen in eine in in eine sinnvolle Anwendung. Ähm.
Und was hier passiert ist, ähm ich vereinfache es, ne, dieses Event hat einen hat einen Code und wenn dieser Code,
veröffentlicht wird, dann werden diejenigen alarmiert, die diesen Code bei sich gespeichert haben. Das heißt, hier werden,
Orte, an denen ihr eincheckt, wieder nur auf eurem Telefon gespeichert und nicht, wie beim Lukas-System live,
online bei Luca im System. Ja, was übrigens auch den,
in großen Teilen Deutschlands wahrscheinlich entscheidenden Vorteil hat, dass ein Check-In offline funktioniert. Ja, also mit Luca werdet ihr in Regionen, wo es kein Internet gibt, ähm.
Schwer einchecken können, umso erstaunlicher, dass Mecklenburg-Vorpommern als erstes auf dieses System gesetzt hat, aber es ist ein anderes Thema. Ähm.
Oder überhaupt Deutschland.
Im System, was Internet.
Online soll das funktionieren? Ja, hm, da haben wir noch gar nicht nachgedacht.
Ja, also du, also, ne, das ist das, was dezentral ist. Also, nur auf eurem Gerät ist gespeichert, an welchen Locations oder bei an welchen Events ihr eingecheckt habt
Ähm dieser Check-In ist vollkommen anonym und auch die Alarmierung ist anonym. Dadurch, dass nur auf eurem Gerät gespeichert ist, wo ihr eingecheckt habt äh und die Alarmierung durch die Veröffentlichung
dieser Check-In Codes funktioniert. Ähm weiß auch nur euer Gerät, ob es grade alarmiert wurde oder nicht
Ne, bei Luca ist das Ziel ja, zu sagen, diese Person war dort. Liebes Gesundheitsamt, geh dahin, ja und mach denen jetzt irgendwie Ärger. Und außerdem ist natürlich hier.
Weil das Gesundheitsamt nicht dazwischen ist, erfolgt die Alarmierung sehr viel schneller.
Ja, also automatisch, wie wir es von der Corona-Warn-App kennen, ne, du hast dein Testergebnis, du schaltest die Alarmierung frei, du äh alarmierst die Events und du bist fertig. Während ja,
Luca sich rühmt hier eine Anbindung an das Gesundheitsamt zu haben, damit es dort der langsam manuellen Verarbeitung
zugeführt werden kann, was eben auch wieder dem epidemeologischen Sinn der ganzen Idee entgegensteht.
Es gibt natürlich ein Problem bei diesem Check-In Kram generell.
Das ist die geringere Genauigkeit. Ich hatte das hier, glaube ich, auch schon öfter erklärt, aber ich möchte sagen, das, was ich jetzt sage, gilt für Luca und für Corona-Warn-App gleichermaßen. Nämlich, dass,
nur weil zwei Personen in ein gleiches Event oder bei Luca eben eine Location eingecheckt haben, es nicht heißt, dass die sich auch angesteckt haben,
Und das äh,
werde nicht müde, das zu betonen, dass ähm Infektionsgeschehen eben stochastisch ist. Also es nicht so ist, dass es überhaupt die Definition einer Situation gibt,
in der eine Ansteckung zu einhundert Prozent stattfindet. Und weil es das nicht gibt, lässt sich auch keine Operationalisierung dafür finden
Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass man mit der Luca-App ein Check-In in einem Zoo macht
zwanzig Hektar oder was, dann ist relativ klar, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß ist, dass wenn man dort eine Person alarmiert.
Dass diese trotzdem nicht infiziert ist. Ja, also dieses Cluster und sonst was Alarmierungssystem.
Hat eine sehr viel geringere Alarmierungsgüte als die.
Grundfunktion der Corona-Warnapp, diese Abstands- und Zeitmessung über Bluetooth, wo es ja wirklich um die Nähe zwischen zwei Personen geht. Und auch da ist die Alarmierungsgüte eben ähm von,
notwendigerweise einer Reihe an,
gezeichnet, weil es eben nicht eine einhundertprozentige Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit geben kann.
Wenn man aber schon ein System mit so geringerer Genauigkeit baut, dann ist es natürlich sinnvoll, das einfach umso schneller äh äh stattfinden zu lassen.
Und ähm dezentral und anonym zu bauen, weil der Gewinn, den man durch den ganzen Kram hat, eben relativ schmal ist. Ja, und das ist ja auch der Hauptgrund, warum man,
kein zentrales System wie Luca,
bauen sollte. Ähm insofern diese CWA-Funktionalität macht einen soliden Eindruck von der technischen Seite.
Es gab dann auch irgend so ein.
Menschen auf Twitter, der dann das Spiel nachspielen wollte. Ähm wir hatten da ja in der letzten Sendung drüber gesprochen. Enno Lenza hat ja mit der Luca-App mal so einen Code veröffentlicht und dann haben sich da, wurden sechshunderttausend Leute eingecheckt,
Und die Luca-App ist dann abgestürzt. Und dieser ähm Herr wollte das dann jetzt ausprobieren mit der Corona-Warn-App.
Genau das geht eben nicht ja? Also diesen Unterschied muss man glaube ich nochmal konkret erklären. Bei der Luca App haben jetzt sechshunderttausend.
Gab es sechshunderttausend Check-Ins.
An einer Location, weil es ein zentrales System ist. Und das Ding ist implodiert, weil es ein zentrales System ist. Wenn man das gleiche Experiment mit der Corona-Warnapp macht.
Dann speichern ja die eingecheckten immer nur auf ihren eigenen Geräten, dass sie dort waren,
Das heißt, eine Überlastung des Luka-Systems findet äh oder eines Corona-Warn-App-Systems kann gar nicht stattfinden, weil es keinen zentralen Server gibt, der sich das alles merken muss. Das ist das eine,
Das Zweite ist, dass du bei Lukay ja Fake-Check-Ins machen kannst, wie du willst.
Mit Sicherheit haben nicht sechshunderttausend Einzelpersonen den QR-Code von Enno Lenze gescannt, sondern da hat halt jemand seinen Fake-Check in Skript einfach mal eine Zeit lang laufen lassen,
ne? Also einem Experiment haben sicherlich Hunderte oder Tausende teilgenommen, aber nicht sechshunderttausend. Ähm und,
würde man nun in der Corona-Warnapp machen, das geht nicht.
Man kann also man kann es nicht machen, weil ein Check-In darin besteht, dass man auf seinem eigenen Gerät das speichert. Also man kann gar keine fake Check-ins in der Corona-Warnapp machen, weil es keine zentralisierte Infrastruktur gibt, die man täuschen könnte.
Und diese das ist natürlich eine Resilienz dieses Systems, dass halt einfach dafür sorgt, dass die Datenhaltung eben dezentral ist und deswegen diese Angriffsfläche und diese ganzen Probleme,
nicht hat. Und deswegen ist das eben ein riesiges Problem bei der Luca-App,
dass man das Ding mit mit Müllzug knallen kann, dass man Leute einchecken kann, die nie da waren.
Ähm und in der Corona-Warn-App einfach kein Angriffsszenario. Und das ist natürlich schwer zu erklären, weil Leute, die sich nicht mit der Infrastruktur darunter auseinandersetzen, sehen QR-Code und sagen.
Genau.
Und dann ist aber auch schon der Gedankengang zu Ende. So.
Ja, genau.
Ähm also das nochmal zur Erläuterung des Unterschieds dieser beiden.
Systeme mit anderen Worten. Was das am Ende auch heißt und das, denke ich, muss man nochmal festhalten. Bei der Corona-Warn-App bekommst du nur,
Notifications für Events und Locations, wo du selber mit deinem Gerät den QR-Code gescannt hast.
Bei der Luka-App kriegst du zusätzlich noch die ganzen Events, wo irgendjemand anders dich eingecheckt hast und du kriegst keine Notification, sondern Anruf vom Gesundheitsamt, der potentiell sogar sanktionsbehaftet ist. Und,
ja, da ist natürlich schon klar, für welches System man sich im Zweifel.
Ich möchte gar nicht ich möchte gar nicht wissen, wie viele äh Anrufe vom Gesundheitsamt Karl Lauterbach bekommt, weil er einfach sich in allen Zoos Deutschlands äh äh sozusagen schon gemeldet hat.
Sehr umtriebig, Herr.
Ja, so. Das äh der kriegt nicht genug.
Dieses Fake-Check in Problemen das kriegt Luca auch nicht weg.
Das können die nicht wegkriegen. Das liegt daran, dass sie äh diese Verschlüsselung haben. Und würden sie nun Maßnahmen ergreifen und sie werden es im Zweifelsfall auch tun, deswegen sage ich das jetzt auch hier, ne. Wenn sie jetzt Maßnahmen ergreifen,
unterbinden,
dann können sie das nur tun, indem sie die Anonymität aufweichen. Und das ist ihr zentrales Versprechen. Ja, das heißt, äh sie können diesen fundamentalen Fehler ihres Systems nur verhindern, indem sie ein,
äh also ein ein weiteres ihrer Versprechen sprechen. Okay, kommen wir aber jetzt mal ganz kurz zu äh der letzten Woche in Sachen Luca. Das war ja dann.
Will mal sagen, erstaunlich.
Wir haben ja als CCC ein äh Statement veröffentlicht, in dem wir ähm auf die verschiedenen Schwächen des Lukasystems hinweisen.
Und äh uns vor allem die Frage stellen,
wie es passieren konnte, dass nun ich glaube dreizehn Bundesländer insgesamt mehr als zwanzig Millionen Euro in dieses Ding versenkt haben,
Ähm ich habe hierzu mal die Chris Köver von Netz Politik org gefragt, die sich ja äh mit der digitalen Pandemiebekämpfung,
eben auch als Journalistin recherchier recherchierend auseinandersetzt und habe sie mal gefragt, ob sie schon erfahren hat, was, was die Kosten für Sormas sind. Sormas ist dieses ähm.
Glaube Open-Force Tool, was in den Gesundheitsämtern verwendet wird und das ist das, woran Luca andocken soll.
Also in zunehmenden Maße verwendet werden soll, ne? Da ist diese Umstellung noch nicht vollständig. Ähm sollte eigentlich erst im Laufe dieses Jahres äh abgeschlossen sein, wie weit das jetzt im Einzelnen ist. Weiß ich nicht, aber es ist bestimmt noch nicht überall am Start.
Genau das andere war.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Ja, also hm Sommer ist auf jeden Fall das contact tracing Datensammeltool, was in den Gesundheitsämtern zur zum Einsatz kommen soll. Also was zentral für diese Arbeit ist die Gesundheitsämter grade versuchen zu erledigen.
Und.
An das eben auch Luca Daten liefern soll. So ja, dass das der Unique Selling Point von Luca. So und also was Chris bisher in Erfahrung bringen konnte ist, die Kosten für Sormas waren insgesamt fünf Millionen.
Und Luca haben wir jetzt schon zwanzig zugeschoben. Während der Sommers Rollout, wie du sagst.
Noch gar nicht ähm abgeschlossen.
Und der auch vor allem unterfinanziert ist und deswegen dauert es so lange
Ja, es gibt einfach da nicht genug Leute, die mit diesem Rollout bei vierhundert Gesundheitsämtern beschäftigt werden können, weil das bedeutet ja immer
Analyse der Ist-Situation, Migration der Systeme, Training, Schulung für die Leute, äh Support, ne, also das
Das ist sozusagen nichts, was man mal eben runterlädt und installiert und dann läuft das, sondern natürlich muss sowas in so einen Prozess reingebracht werden, Leute müssen damit vertraut gemacht werden. Die haben vorher so gemacht, jetzt müssen sie's so machen
dauert einfach seine Zeit. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, ich kannte die Zahl noch nicht. Fünf Millionen hat man da reingesteckt, um irgendwie erstmal das Betriebssystem der Gesundheitsämter zu installieren und das.
Dauert schon zu lange und es wäre ja eigentlich toll, wenn's schneller gehen würde. Aber dann für eine Software, die irgendwie unterm Strich eigentlich gar nichts bringt, gibt man zwanzig Millionen aus. Ja,
um sich an ein System anzudocken, was noch gar nicht installiert ist, äh da fällt einem ja gar nichts mehr zu ein.
Naja da fällt einem wirklich nichts mit zu ein. Und äh deswegen haben wir auch dieses Statement vom CCC veröffentlicht und haben gesagt, so stoppt das, ne? Das ist eine Millionengrab
und vor allem, was hier ja passiert, was möchte ich auch nochmal wiederholen, ist ja die Förderung eines dauerhaften Geschäftsmodell für Check-Ins und Ticketing, was diese Startups da versucht zu etablieren, wo es jetzt eigentlich zwanzig Millionen staatliche Förderung für bekommt. Nun, wir haben dieses Statement veröffentlicht.
Und ähm ich sage mal so, wir waren ja vorgewarnt, von Eva Wolfang.
Dass diese Leute mit allen Mitteln gegen Kritiker vorgehen,
Zu diesen Mitteln gehört, dass äh sehr viele Leute, die jetzt, sage ich mal, das CCC-Statement getwittert haben.
So per DM von denen angeschrieben wurden.
Zu diesen, zu dieser Reaktion gehört, dass ihr in so 'n achtseitige, wirklich, völlig, völlig wirres äh Ding geschrieben haben, in der sie ähm behaupten, auf die CCC Kritik zu,
was aber tatsächlich eigentlich nur so eine so eine Parade an Strohmännern ist, wo sie quasi die Argumente, die wir anbringen,
wegzerren und etwas anderes anbringen. Zum Beispiel sagen wir,
Das Geschäftsmodell ist zweifelhaft, das ist natürlich klar, ich meine, ist ein privates Unternehmen, was Ticketing und Check-In machen möchte und sie sagen dem entgegen, ne, es wäre transparent, aber transparent ist ja kein Gegensatz von
zweifelhaft, ja, also etwas kann ja transparent und zweifelhaft sein und das ist bei denen ja auch der Fall. Es ist halt zweifelhaftes, ziemlich durchschaubares Geschäftsmodell. Ähm also da brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht drauf einzugehen.
Spannend sind dann so Sachen wie ähm Smudo, der dann, sage ich mal, seine Äußerungen so so Sachen sagt wie,
Luca nicht mehr von Lockdown zu Lockdown und das ist net, also ne, das heißt also er sagt spezifisch,
Mit diesem Tool brauchen, haben wir keine Lockdowns mehr. Und das ist eine Aussage, die in keiner Form haltbar ist, ne? Das ist genau diese falschen Heilsversprechen, die wir kritisieren.
Was er auch sagt, ist der CCC sagt stopp Luca, ich sage Stopp covid. Ja, es ist auch wieder, ne, genau diese diese,
Ja, also es ist so.
Genau, weil weil wir sind ja, wir sind ja pro covid, ne? Ist ja klar, ne? Ja, ja.
Covid. Wir sind pro covid und du nicht. Also wirklich.
Ne, du musst also du musst dich da echt zusammenreißen. Weißt du, wenn ich das nicht der Höhepunkt ähm.
Es gab dann hier von den äh von, sagen wir mal, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ansässigen Verlagen oder von einem äh also von so einem Zeitungskonglomerat, die Überschrift, jetzt halte ich fest hin. Falsch
völliger Schwachsinn. Chef der Luca-App knöpft sich Kritiker vor.
In der er äh ja also äh und das das ist wirklich, also das ist die Krönung, ja? Also wer jetzt noch irgendwie einen Eindruck haben möchte, mit was für Leuten wir hier zu tun haben, die stellen sich ernsthaft hin.
Und sagen, dass diese Luca-Track-Schwachstelle keine Schwachstelle sei,
und das haben die mehrfach getan und zwar explizit. Ich wurde dann von einem Journalisten mit Namen Thomas Koreanovic ähm,
Mit folgender Aussage konfrontiert bevor sie veröffentlicht wurde, ja? Also ich zitiere jetzt hier,
Patrick Hennig, das ist einer der Covid-Glücksritter, der sagt Folgendes,
Es handelt sich dabei um keine Sicherheitslücke, auch wenn der Chaos Computerclub das behauptet.
Jeder Schlüsselanhänger ist, wie die eigene Telefonnummer statisch. Er ist dafür gedacht, dass auch jemand ohne Smartphone ein System teilnehmen kann. Der Schlüssel selbst ist auf dem Schlüsselanhänger im QR-Code und der Seriennummer hinterlegt.
Kleine Anmerkung von mir. Das ist die Schwachstelle.
Daher so weiter, Patrick Hennig, daher empfehlen wir, den Schlüsselanhänger vertraulich aufzubewahren,
Anmerkungen von mir. Man soll damit einchecken und verrät damit den Schlüssel. Das ist die Schwachstelle.
Patrick Hennig. Im vorgeworfenen Beispiel hat ein dritter Sichtbesitz über den Schlüsselanhänger verschafft und dann seine eigenen Daten abgerufen.
Äh Anmerkungen von mir. Es ist ein QR-Code, den fotografiert man. Den muss man nicht besitzen,
Und das in dem Beispiel die eigenen Daten abgerufen wurden, ist ja,
klar, weil es eine Demonstration einer Schwachstelle ist, dass man da jetzt nicht eine real existierende Person nimmt.
Sollte auch einleuchtend sein. Und,
er hier sagt, dritter hätte sich Besitz über einen Schlüsselanhänger verschafft, das ist halt so, ne? Dieses spezifischen ähm,
Formulierungen, die ja sehr schwer haltbar sind, aber natürlich etwas sehr böses ähm dem Tobias Ravenstein und der Bianca unterstellen, die diese Schwachstelle gefunden und veröffentlicht haben.
So und dann sagt er, wir haben weitere Maßnahmen getroffen, um den Effekt des Verlustes zu minimieren. Es geht nicht um Verlust. Man checkt mit diesem Ding ein.
Sagt er generell, generell gilt, normalerweise informiert man erst den Hersteller, räumt eine angemessene Frist zu Beseitigung ein und geht danach an die Öffentlichkeit. Da sitzen wir nur verwundert da und fragen uns, warum werden wir medial geschlachtet,
wieso wird die Diskussion nicht sachlich geführt? Klassiker ne? Also wir können immer wieder darauf lenken.
Ja
Die Versachlichung der Debatte fordert.
Und jetzt äh weiter Patrick Hennig, die Sicherheitsprobleme, auf die der Chaos Computerclub anspielt, lassen sich technisch leicht erklären und damit ausräumen.
Äh ist schon echt krass, ja. Wir haben keine Sicherheitsbedenken,
Trotzdem wird getan, als ob das alles ganz schlimm sei. Dadurch werden die Öffentlichkeit und die Politik stark verunsichert, dabei liegt die Vermutung nahe, dass hier eine eigene Agenda verfolgt wird.
So, mit diesem Statement hat mich der Journalist ähm konfrontiert.
Und ähm ich habe dem dann widersprochen und habe gesagt, so, also passen Sie auf, ne? Das ist hier eine Schwachstelle, ist ein Verstoß gegen das Versprechen. Dass Luca ja seinen eigenen Nutzerinnen macht.
Und habe außerdem gesagt, äh er möge bitte Herrn Hennig bitten, zu konkretisieren, den Vorwurf einer eigenen Agenda, die der Chaos Computerclub verfolgen würde, damit wir uns dazu auch äußern können.
Ne, das also halte ich jetzt für eine angemessene Reaktion, wenn ein Journalist mich mit einer solchen.
Aussage konfrontiert. Also erstens muss man ja sagen, da komme ich gleich nochmal zu, ist einfach eine,
nicht gedeckte Tatsachenbehauptung von Herrn Hennig, dass es sich dabei um eine Sicherheit nicht um eine Sicherheitslücke handeln würde, ne? Der kann ich ja dann als unabhängiger Experte ähm entgegentreten. Ähm,
Also ich habe dem widersprochen und habe dann festgestellt, dass meine Richtigstellung der Behauptung von Patrick Hennig ignoriert wurde. Das wurde so gedruckt, in der,
Berliner Zeitung. Am Sonntag, ich habe dann auch den Journalisten gefragt, wie es denn dazu käme, dass,
ob ich zu spät geantwortet hätte oder so. Nö, aber er meinte, das wäre also deckungsgleich. Ich hätte dem Herrn Hennig ja nicht widersprochen und deswegen hätte er sich äh dazu entschieden, ähm dass.
Zu ignorieren, was ich dazu gesagt habe. Das habe ich natürlich schon ein bisschen überrascht und da fragt man sich ja, also auch wirklich so, es ist beeindruckend, wie sowas zustande kommt. Und deswegen muss ich jetzt eigentlich mal sagen so.
Also der Satz, es handelt sich dabei um keine Sicherheitslücke,
dem habe ich entgegen zu halten, so ist ein zentrales Sicherheitsversprechen von Luca, das kein Tracking stattfindet. Die Behauptung, dass das nur funktionieren würde, wenn jemand seinen Schlüsselanhänger verliert, ist falsch. Und.
Und dadurch, dass sie die Schwachstelle ja selber dann auch beseitigt haben erkennen sie ja an, dass es eine ist,
Insofern trifft Herr Hennig hier halt wirklich eine.
Tatsachenbehauptung, die entweder darauf schließen lässt, dass er grundsätzlich kein Verständnis vom eigenen System hat oder dass er hier wieder besseren Wissen eine Schwachstelle leugnet, die er selber anerkannt und beseitigt hat.
Und das finde ich schon wirklich ähm ziemlich hart. Ja und das könnte man jetzt ja so raus sein, als würde ich den Herrn Hennig der Lüge bezichtigen,
Und wenn ich das tue
dann kann ich mir sicher sein, dass er sich dagegen auch nicht zur Wehr setzen kann, weil es unstrittig ist, dass es eine Schwachstelle und ein Verstoß gegen die eigenen Sicherheitsversprechen von und der Luca-App ist. Insofern, das ist äh,
Also da habe ich gestaunt. Mit sowas hätte ich nicht gerechnet, ne? Und aber man hat ja oder wir haben ja von.
Eva Wolf Angel äh auch dann schon die Geschichten gehört, dass sie,
sich dann bei der Chefredaktion über sie beschwert haben und was nicht alles, also die kämpfen da wirklich mit ganz anderen Maßnahmen. Als man die äh ja erwarten würde, ne, man hätte,
Also die hätten ja eine Sache, die die Option steht ja immer frei. Als äh Betroffener einer Sicherheitslücke.
Anständig das anzuerkennen, der Community, die es dir gemeldet hat zu danken.
Und äh Besserung zu loben. Das ist auch, also ich meine, ist die einzige Möglichkeit, die belastbar ist und nur sehr unerfahrene oder sehr.
Also sehr aggressive Personen würden von diesem, von dieser Idee abweichen. Ja.
Und das ist das, was äh die hier tun, das äh zeigt natürlich davon, dass die ähm.
Ja, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen skrupelloser sind, als das in der Community eigentlich äh üblich wäre.
Das ist schon ziemlich krass. Also ich wäre gespannt, äh ob die auch nur eine unabhängige Expertin finden, die der Ansicht ist, dass das keine Schwachstelle gewesen sei und das ist schon, also.
Also mir ist völlig unklar, was da los war. Es gab übrigens auch dann noch ähm ich kann es nicht anders nennen, aber so eine Art Gefälligkeitspodcast des Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten von Baden-Württemberg, der ja eigentlich.
Aufgabe hat.
Diese App im Interesse und im Auftrag der Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu prüfen und ähm in diesem Podcast wird Luca Track noch nicht mal erwähnt,
Auch da fragst du dich so,
was ist denn los? Also wirklich, was ist denn hier los, ja? Äh vielleicht wird das vorher aufgenommen, aber dann würde man ja seine Veröffentlichung anpassen, wenn dann halt eine schwerwiegende Schwachstelle ähm öffentlich bekannt geworden ist. Also das ist äh schon.
Äh faszinierend gewesen. Ja und äh ich glaube, ich muss hier an dieser Stelle nicht betonen, dass der Computerclub seit vierzig Jahren äh Schwachstellen aufdeckt und meldet und sicherlich,
keine andere eigene Agenda verfolgt, als die Öffentlichkeit vor vor windigen Geschäftemachern und äh unsicheren Systemen zu warnen. Ja, das ist äh.
Also die die Unverfrorenheit ist schon wirklich ähm ja, faszinierend.
Vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal so eine andere Kritik, die ich auch so nebenbei noch mitbekommen habe, äh zu kontern, ja. Es gibt ja auch so Leute, die sagen so, ja,
äh der CCC, jetzt wo man's vielleicht sinnbildlich für auch eine ganze Szene, ja, äh verhindert ja auch Innovation.
Weil wir ja immer an allem rummäkeln und irgendwie, was weiß ich, Zoemaßstäbe ansetzen und wer würde denn dann da überhaupt noch sich trauen, ein Start-up zu gründen, äh
in so einem, in so einer Atmosphäre, wo er wo man Angst haben muss, dass der böse große, mächtige CCC da irgendwie sein, sein sein Wort erhebt.
Leute, der CCC, ja, das ist irgendwie ein Haufen von,
Experten, die sich irgendwie an der an der Frontlinie irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit äh bemühen, die teilweise selber im Security-Business sind, äh teilweise aber auch nicht gestützt von einem.
Netzwerk von,
freiwilligen Nerds, Helfern, anderen Aktivisten, Verwandten, Gruppen, ähnlicher äh und auch manchmal ganz anderer Natur, ja, die,
überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind, irgendwie eine großes
Agenda Setting zu betreiben, sondern im Wesentlichen eigentlich auch immer nur reagieren auf diesen ganzen Unsinn, der irgendwie auf einen zukommt. Und wenn man
in der Lage ist irgendwie eine Startup Kultur zu starten, ja? Die vielleicht auch einfach mal so ein paar von diesen Grundsätzen einfach mal von vornherein mal im Gedankengang berücksichtigt
Wenn man das tut, dann ist man da sowieso schon relativ frei, dann kümmert sich irgendwie der Club äh äh eigentlich um sowas auch überhaupt.
Sondern haben einfach genug damit zu tun, auf die Sachen einzuschlagen, die ich jetzt wirklich einfach mal völlig neben der Spur sind oder die zumindest versuchen, in der Öffentlichkeit deutlich besser dazustehen, äh als es eigentlich angemessen wäre.
Ich möchte da noch einen wichtigen Aspekt äh anmerken, Tim. Äh insbesondere die Frage der Innovation,
Also, eine zentrale Datenbank der Bewegung von Bürgerinnen zu machen, ist jetzt nicht ein besonders innovatives Konzept.
Die Innovation ist tatsächlich in so etwas wie Crowd Notifyer oder dem, was äh jetzt an Crowd-Notifyer angelegt in die Corona-Warn-App eingebaut wurde. Schnell.
Anonym, dezentral und zwar eine Lösung, die auf ein spezifisches Problem fokussiert.
Sich das dessen annimmt und die bestmögliche und schnellste Option dafür baut,
ja? Das ist Innovation. Eine zentrale Datenbank zu bauen, es keine Innovation. Das äh ist wirklich einfach keine Innovation. Was ich sehr im, übrigens amüsant finde, um jetzt nur mal so.
Also um nochmal hier auf der dieses Statement, ja? Äh CCC-Vorwurf Doppelpunkt, eklatante Menge in der Spezifikation.
Also was bedeutet Spezifikation? Eine Software wird spezifiziert. Ja, man schreibt also, unser System funktioniert folgendermaßen und nicht so. Ja, wir machen ein zentrales System und da wird verschlüsselt und und alle müssen online sein, um sich da einzuchecken. Das ist die Spezifikation,
Dem entgegnen sie uns die die kennen den Begriff der Spezifikation nicht.
Weil sie sagen dann, also sie entgegnen dem, wir sagen die, die Spezifikation hat Mängel und dem sagen sie, wir haben uns für den Reflexierungsfehler entschuldigt,
meinen damit, dass sie hier eben Software von anderen gestohlen hatten, ohne
das äh richtig anzuerkennen. Wir haben darüber ja gesprochen, ja. Also da geht es aber nicht um die Spezifikation, sondern geht es um die Lizenzierung. Und das heißt, die kennen.
Entweder wissen die nicht, wann eine Spezifikation ist, das würde einiges erklären. Muss ich wirklich sagen, also wenn dann ist eine Menge entschuldigt. So, wenn die nicht wissen, was eine Softwarespezifikation ist, dann sind viele Fehler in dieser Spezifikation ihnen ähm.
Ihnen zu verzeihen, ja, aber dann ist nichts zu verzeihen, dass irgendjemand das kauft. Ja, okay.
Ist wirklich ähm haarsträubend, haarstr.
Verbringen schon wieder zu viel Zeit damit.
Du hast recht. Fassen wir es noch kurz zusammen. Es gibt einen wichtigen äh einen wichtigen Artikel noch von Ralf Rottmann. Der ist heute auf Netzpolitik Orgin erschienen, ähm der das Lizenzmodell kritisiert.
Und zwar ist es ja so, dass wir jetzt schon über zwanzig Millionen Euro in den Wind geschossen haben für dieses System.
Und äh er er führt dort aus, warum Software heutzutage in der Regel äh Software also Service ähm.
Nutzungsbasiert abgerechnet wird. Also, dass du zum Beispiel sagst, okay, wenn das Ding hier irgendwie durch die Decke geht und so, ne, dann kostet dann zahlen wir euch eben, was weiß ich, fünf Cent pro Check in, ne? Und,
Wenn das nicht durch die Decke geht, dann haben wir als als Kundinnen nichts verloren, keine großen Kosten gehabt und ihr keinen großen Gewinn gehabt,
Und er schreibt eben da auch so, dass das Skurrile ist, dass eigentlich dieses Lukading umso profitabler wird für die Erfinder, je weniger es genutzt wird.
Dem habe ich nur noch hinzuzufügen.
Deren Ziel, deren Longterm-Ziel ist, ja nach Covid weiterhin die Check-In und Ticketing-App zu sein. Insofern haben die natürlich auch ein Interesse daran, Erfolg zu haben, aber die haben halt jetzt erstmal, ne, zwanzig Millionen eingestreicht, um diese,
diesen Erfolg zu realisieren. Als Dankeschön kriegt man da jetzt obendrauf noch eine noch weitere Prüfung von anderen Landesdatenschützerinnen und eine Prüfung durch das BSI
Da finde ich, das finde ich sehr lustig, weil als wir damals die Wahl gehackt haben, ne, äh Martin Schiersig, Thorsten Schröder und ich, dieses äh äh PC Wahlding auseinandergenommen haben, nachdem Martin Schier sich da
die sich das Anfangs angeschaut hatte in einem Bundesland. Da haben wir
ähm noch irgendwie so sanft täglich mit dem Innenministerium telefoniert, ne? Und da habe ich gesagt, Leute, warum reitet nicht das BSI ein und fix diesen Krempel?
Ja? Und da wurde mir das geht nicht, weil das wäre ja eine Marktverzerrung, weil es gibt ja mehrere Anbieter auf diesem Markt, der äh Wahl
Auswertungstools. Und es wäre jetzt ein ein Marktverzerrung und ein ein Übervorteilung eines Anbieters, wenn der jetzt ähm Unterstützung durch das BSI bekäme bei der Beseitigung von Schwachstellen.
So, aber wenn erstmal zwanzig Millionen in so eine Luka-App vergeudet wurden, ne, dann kriegst du natürlich noch ein BSI Audit äh kostenlos,
obendrauf. Also das ist wirklich unterhaltsam.
Ist auch ein geiles Argument, mal dafür äh wirklich mal eine eine Bundes ähm äh eine Infrastruktur im Bundesbesitz aufzuziehen, dann kann dann wenigstens auch mal das BSI was fixen.
Ja
Na ja und und wir hätten ja eine, wir haben ja eine eine Corona-Warn-App, die gehen all diese Probleme, ja? Fake, Check-Ins, äh funktioniert nur, wenn's online ist und so nicht hätte.
Skalierung.
Das große Problem der Fake-Check-Ins ist ja.
Das wird überhaupt nicht ausreichend berichtet. Ähm erstens, du müllst die Gesundheitsämter zu, die melden sich übrigens jetzt auch und sagen, das ist alles nur Müll, was da rauskommt. Die Daten wollen wir gar nicht haben. Das kommt sowieso noch, ne?
Aber stell dir mal vor, jemand würde hingehen und würde jetzt in jedem Ort jeden Check in den es so gibt, zwei, drei Fakes drunter streuen.
Wo die Leute immer sagen könnten, ey Entschuldigung, ich war nicht da, ich wohne nicht in der Stadt oder was auch immer, ne? Du hättest oder du hast als jemand, der vom Gesundheitsamt aufgrund eines Luka-Check-Ins angerufen wird, immer,
Die Niability. Immer. Kannst einfach sagen, nö. Geh, weiß doch jeder. Gucken sie mal. Hier, ich kann ihnen zeigen, wie man Fake-Check-In macht,
Wie wollen Sie mir hier irgendwie unterstellen, dass ich da war? Und ähm dem entgegnen.
Diese Luca, Leute? Ja, ja, aufm Blatt Papier können die Leute ja auch immer falsche Daten schreiben,
aber aufm Blatt Papier, dann muss ich da wenigstens hingehen. Was Luca ist, ist ein großes Blatt Papier in der Mitte des Internets, wo jeder reinschreiben kann, was er will.
Und das gilt für alle lokale gleichermaßen. Und,
Also so ist diesen konzeptionellen Fehler nicht verstanden zu haben und nicht zu verstehen, warum die Corona-Warn-App äh,
absolut überlegen. Es gab gar keine Frage. Ja, äh ist halt schon eine Katastrophe. Entsprechend wird auch auf Zeit online von ähm.
Glaube, Jakob von Lindern war der Name, äh auch gefordert zu sagen, so, ey, jetzt haben wir eine staatliche, saubere Infrastruktur,
schnell, anonym dezentral. Dieser diese gesamte Idee des Zwanges, Quarantänezwang und der Staat und wir halten dich jetzt hier fest, sowieso Unsinn.
Schaffe doch jetzt in den Verordnungen diese Kontakt äh Datenerfassung ab. Wenn es doch ein schnelleres System gibt,
ja? Und äh geht diesen Weg, ja? Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, wäre ja echt super, dass man sagt, pass auf, Corona-Warn-App oder.
Wenn du die nicht benutzen möchtest, dann muss halt deine Adresse eingeben. Das wäre mal eine faire, äh ein fairer Vergleich, um zu sagen, so hier, da siehst du eben, wir bieten dir ja das Schnellste,
und anonyme Tool an
was wir finanziert haben, was ohne Risiko ist. Und wenn du dem nicht traust, dann schreib eben deine Adresse auf einen Zettel, dann wird deine Adresse ans Gesundheitsamt weitergegeben. Das wäre, sage ich mal so,
Als äh kannst du eben auch deine Adresse dalassen. Das wäre, sage ich mal, eine eine informierte äh informierter Umgang mit den mit den Risiken und vor allem nochmal, ne, es geht hier dabei nur darum, schnell genug zu alarmieren
damit die Leute dann ihre Kontakte reduzieren. Und deswegen ist die Geschwindigkeit der Alarmierung so wichtig.
Aber ja, solange wir irgendwie Jan Josef Liefers und Ben Becker am quengeln haben, brauchen wir uns, glaube ich, über die äh ja die Qualität der und Informiertheit der äh Corona
App-Debatten nicht zu wundern.
Politik muss ich hier echt an die Nase fassen, also falsche Voraussetzungen, falsche Rahmenbedingungen, falsche Entscheidungen,
am Ende auch noch eine verpasste Chance, weil zu wissen, dass so ein Feature in der Corona-Warn-App ohnehin in der Entwicklung ist
Das denkt sich das Team doch nicht selber aus. Das ist doch
Auftrag, das ist doch vom Bund gewollt gewünscht und wird dann entsprechend umgesetzt, weil dann wird es ja auch
bezahlt. Die drehen doch nicht frei und Däumchen und machen da irgendwie ihr eigenes Ding. Das war doch sowieso schon unterwegs, das Feature. Wenn das sowieso schon unterwegs ist, warum wissen das die Länder nicht? Warum kriegen die das nicht gesagt, dass das sozusagen sowieso kommt?
Dass es dann auch noch die beste Lösung ist, weil es eben nicht zusätzliche Last auf die Gesundheitsämter legt, die jetzt irgendwie immer gucken muss, wenn irgendwie ein Vorfall ist, ah okay, jetzt haben wir also hier irgendwie sechshunderttausend Leute im Zoo
Was machen wir denn da jetzt damit? Das ist ja noch mal mehr Arbeit,
Die sollen entlastet werden. Die werden damit nicht entlastet. Entlastet werden sie durch die Corona-Warnapp und würde man darauf hinweisen, dann,
Würden auch mehr Leute diese App runterladen und dann würden sie sie auch benutzen und dann würde auch die ursprüngliche Funktion nochmal besser. Und dieses ganze Argument, man könnte das ja irgendwie nicht befördern. Mein Gott,
einmal irgendwohin schreiben, jeder Laden in Deutschland, der aufhaben muss, äh aufhaben möchte.
Dieses DIN A4 Papier auszudrücken. Und da ist irgendwie ein QR-Code mit einem Link auf die App drauf.
Und äh also so naheliegend alles, so einfach, so kostenlos und trotzdem wird's nicht gemacht und stattdessen.
Müssen wir jetzt irgendwie mit so einer, so einer Debatte rumschlagen, die eigentlich letztes Jahr schon äh komplett durch war.
Das ist wirklich ähm na ja. Jetzt hoffe, wir wollen's nie wieder was davon hören. Nie wieder,
Nehmt das Scheißgeld geht aber geht mit Gott aber geht bitte OK.
Genau. Nimmt nimmt einfach die Kohle, setzt euch auf eure Insel, macht eine Party mit euren Pieps irgendwie und haltet's Maul und lasst uns einfach in Frieden. Wir haben hier irgendwie eine Krise zu bewältigen.
Wir müssen uns ernsthaft dann irgendwann mal darüber Gedanken machen, wie es zu so einem,
wie es zu seinem absoluten Desaster kommen kann. Das nochmal zu in Ruhe zu analysieren, das ist ein schmerzhaftes schmerzhafte, dunkle Hülle, in die wir kriechen müssen. Das tut mir leid.
Okay. Halbwegs gute Nachrichten. Ja, eigentlich nur ein bisschen äh Hacker äh Heldenstories. Ähm vor einiger Zeit
Also es gibt dieses Unternehmen mit dem Namen. Denn die haben sich im Prinzip auf die Forensik an Geräten
spezialisiert. Also bietet an, ne? Die Polizei oder ein Geheimnisse, wer auch immer hat ein Gerät, ein Smartphone in ihren Händen.
Möchten gerne die Daten auslesen, dann bietet Celebrite quasi so ein Toolset an, diese äh Geräte äh auszulesen,
und das natürlich auch äh unter Ausnutzung von Schwachstellen auf den Geräten, ja, wenn also, wie es bei älteren äh iPhones, ich glaube bis zur sechs oder sechs S, dieser Boot
und so
diese diese Dinge finden da alle Anwendungen, äh um in um in die Geräte reinzukommen und sie auszulesen. Ja?
Und hat jetzt vor ein paar Wochen ähm relativ medienwirksam angekündigt. Ja, also wir können jetzt übrigens auch Signal auslesen. Und das.
Also was das bedeutet, muss man jetzt auch mal sagen, so das heißt nicht, sie haben Signal gehackt, sondern sie es heißt einfach nur, dass ihr Parsa für Daten jetzt auch das interne Datenformat von Signal,
ja, auslesen kann, ne? Also wenn du jetzt so eine App hast und eine Signal App, die speichert natürlich die Nachrichten auf dem Telefon.
Und wenn äh du jetzt diese Datenbank ausliest oder dieses Dateiformat ausliest, äh und verstehst und zwar auf die Weise verstehst, wie es die App versteht, dann kannst du eben auch diese Chats.
Darstellen in einer Weise, äh wie du das eben äh für richtig hältst. Und äh.
Dieser Teil
das nennt sich äh also dieser Parsa, der diese ganzen Daten auseinandernimmt, äh nennt sich der und der andere Teil des ähm Celebrited System ist der UVD, das ist quasi das System, was ähm
ein Backup macht
Ja, die die imitieren im Prinzip äh Android oder iTunes oder macOS, ne, um Backup von dem System, von dem von dem von dem Gerät zu machen und dann haben sie eben den, der die Daten, die da, die dieses,
dann eben ausliest. So funktionieren diese Dinge und dann sagen sie am Ende hier pass auf das und das war der Fall.
Jetzt äh wie es der Zufall will, äh ist irgendwo so ein Ding vom äh vom LKW gefallen und ähm.
Landete bei äh bei Signal, ja? Und ähm die haben dann sich damit auseinandergesetzt, wie dieses äh funktioniert und äh haben.
In dem.
Haben also was weiß ich, sich das Spyder angeschaut und so, ne und haben festgestellt, dass da so typische ähm drin fehlen, also eine Verteidigung dieser Software,
und ist eine Reihe an Schwachstellen gibt, die man ausnutzen kann. Ein Beispiel, was sie benennen ist, dass irgendwie ein zehn Jahre altes FFM-Pack drin ähm,
Und sie sagen aber auch, dass das nicht die mit denen sie sich ansonsten noch weiter auseinandergesetzt haben. Was sie dann veröffentlichen ist ein Video, bei dem also mit diesem Tool.
Ein Smartphone ausgelesen und analysiert wird und dann auf einmal äh einen Pop-Up aufblinkt auf diesem Rechner.
Und da steht irgendwie sowas wie äh.
Oder sowas ne? Also leg dich mit dem Besten an und so und du bist erledigt wie der Rest auch,
Ja, was heißt das? Die haben also einen Weg gefunden in diesem in dem dass man dem eine Datei gibt, die wenn er die,
versucht zu verarbeiten, ähm dass er offensichtlich ein, ich würde jetzt schätzen, aber
ne? Mehr schreiben sie dazu nicht. Ich würde jetzt schätzen, dass sie da einen Buffer Overflow ausnutzen oder irgendeine eine Command Injection oder so. Und dann Abitur auf dem Zielsystem ausführen können,
und sagen eine typische Handlungsmöglichkeit, die ihn dadurch offen stünde, wäre zum Beispiel die also die Ergebnisberichte,
und zukünftige Nachlust und äh Laune zu verändern. Und äh das ist natürlich also so Kudos.
Eins A, feinstes Hacking, feinstes Hacking, Prädikat, feinstes Hacking und dann sagen sie ähm,
Wir sind natürlich bereit, äh im Rahmen einer responsible, die Schwachstellen, die wir hier gefunden haben, Celebritan mitzuteilen, wenn?
Sie das auch machen mit allen Schwachstellen, die die bei ihrer Physikal Extraction.
Bei ihren anderen Dienstleistungen zum Einsatz bringen,
Hier muss man kurz sagen nutzt laut eigene Angabe für neuere iPhones haben sie angeblich, also sagen sie, gibt es die sie nutzen?
Um da quasi auch diese Backups einzuleiten. Aber bei diesen Explods handelt es sich vermutlich oder in großer Sicherheit eben um,
und um das Risiko zu minimieren, dass diese Explod-Zeit in die Öffentlichkeit geraten vom LKW fallen und in den Händen von maximalen Spike landen, bieten sie,
Das nur als Service an. Das heißt, sie sagen, okay, die Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder Geheimdienste können uns ein Gerät einschicken, wir hacken dieses Gerät für die und schicken ihnen dann die Daten zurück.
Was natürlich total problematisch ist, weil eine Forensikerin,
Geheimnisse, bei der Polizei, natürlich für die Ergebnisse gerade stehen muss. Und wenn du hier dich einer externen Dienstleisterin bedienst.
Wir haben das gehackt, hier sind die Ergebnisse, aber wir sagen denen nicht, wie wir das gemacht haben, dann äh ist das natürlich ein ein großes Problem. Und darauf
Signe, dass sie sagen, so, passt auf, wenn ihr hier die Oldies äh droppt so,
Dann droppen wir auch unsere, aber wenn solange ihr kein macht, müsst ihr, könnt ihr diesen Anspruch auch nicht an uns stellen.
Oh meinst, das ist soviel.
Ey du, es ist wirklich so ähm.
Ah, ganz toll, ja. Ähm.
Ganz, ganz toll, ja? Und ähm außerdem schreiben sie.
Völlig unrelated so unabhängig von dem, was wir jetzt da geschrieben haben. Zukünftige Versionen von Signal werden sich regelmäßig ein paar Dateien aus dem Internet herunterladen und in App-Storage legen.
Diese Dateien werden nie benutzt werden.
Werden niemals mit Signal interagieren, aber ähm wir speichern dir einfach mal auf eurem Gerät.
Und es ist natürlich sehr naheliegend oder man könnte sich jetzt vorstellen, dass diese Dateien halt Explodes für Celebrite beinhalten. Das wäre natürlich totaler Wahnsinn. Äh aber es kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass sie so etwas machen würden.
Also richtig schöner, geiler Hackback sozusagen. Diesmal richtig.
Ich denke, ähm ich weiß nicht, ist das ein äh.
Na ja, die haben zurückgehackt.
Nö, die haben die haben halt einen Exploit gefunden und haben sich mit der Disclosure Policy des Unternehmens auseinandergesetzt, haben festgestellt, oho, die nehmen an der Responsible Disclosure,
Kultur nicht teil.
Entsprechend sehen wir uns jetzt auch nicht denen gegenüber verpflichtet an der Kultur teilzunehmen.
Und äh wir befinden uns also hier gemeinsam auf hoher See.
Und handeln nach den Regeln, die die uns vorgegeben haben.
Ah, traumhaft, ja. Ich meine, deswegen äh ich liebe die. Ich liebe die. Signal,
Deswegen nutze ich Signal. Okay.
Machen wir ähm noch kurz weiter. Wir hatten darüber gesprochen, dass äh Frontex ja die Agentur äh ist, die.
Vierundneunzigtausend Euro Abendessen ausrichtet.
Lecker.
Und die hatten ja jetzt eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage von frag den Staat irgendwie zurückgewiesen und ihnen eine äh Rechnung über ich weiß nicht, ob über fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro oder sowas waren das,
Das Gericht hat dann bestätigt, dass dass sie über einhundert Prozent zu viel verlangt hatten, ja? Ah genau, dreiundzwanzigtausendsiebenhundert Euro wollten sie haben.
Äh und ne, dass quasi diese Forderung viel zu hoch war und ähm ja, frag den Staat, hat Recht bekommen, dass das,
oder dass das
dass die Agentur mit ihrem Milliardenbudget, die für vierundneunzigtausend Euro Abendessen gehen, ähm mit dreiundzwanzigtausendsiebenhundert Euro von frag den Staat viel zu viel Geld verlangt hat und dass das eine Maßnahme war, um,
dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz entgegenzutreten
und ihr den Informationsfreiheitsansprüchen, die äh über frag den Staat gegenüber Frontex. Ähm erhoben wurden. Insofern, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch zum
oder zum zum Sieg in dieser juristischen Auseinandersetzung und ja, ne, also wenn man sich das Budget von Frontex anschaut, das, was da getan wurde, war eben ein spezifischer Versuch.
Fragt den Staat hier zu schaden und fragt den Staat, ist ein demokratisches,
Tool für Transparenz und diesen System schaden zu wollen ist natürlich absolut unangemessen. Natürlich kann man, ne, das ist ja völlig in Ordnung, sich gegen Informationsfreiheitsanfragen.
Ähm denen widersprechen, wenn man dafür einen äh rechtlichen, eine rechtliche Grundlage hat oder ein, ne, das.
Sind nun mal Gesetze, ja, aber quasi dann einen Versuch machen, denen durch ähm übertriebene Forderungen äh einerseits das Funding zu entziehen und ihnen gewissermaßen äh.
Aktiv schaden zu wollen, natürlich mit dem Ziel, dass die weniger Fragen in Zukunft, dass es eben wirklich eine absolut unwürdige Aktion und das wurde hier eben auch höchstrichterlich,
festgestellt.
Ich hoffe, dass sie nicht verhungern jetzt irgendwie, wenn sie nur noch zehntausend Euro für ihr Abendessen bezahlen dürfen.
Nee, die dürfen also theoretisch der Schaden für äh für Frontex ist ja jetzt nur zwei zwölftausend Euro ungefähr. Das heißt, das nächste Abendessen nur für vierundachtzigtausend.
Ja, so ein bisschen, also,
schwächer, ne. Na gut, dann kommen wir in der nächsten Woche nochmal ein bisschen darauf zu sprechen, dass das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei beschlossen wurde und das beschlossen wurde, ähm.
Da würden wir uns nochmal tiefe mit auseinandersetzen und haben jetzt nur nochmal ein bisschen Jobs zu bewerben.
Was gibt's denn Schönes.
Netzflüssig Orks sucht eine Unterstützung in Finanzen und IT,
Wir suchen für anfangs zwanzig Stunden die Woche Unterstützung in Finanzen und IT. Ähm der
aktueller Admin soll unterstützt werden, um die Lasten bis hin zu verteilen, damit er auch mal äh Urlaub machen kann,
ohne dass er eine Notbetreuung der IT leisten muss und äh in der Finanzabteilung soll eine Stelle geschaffen werden, die die Kommunikation,
zum und Lohnabrechnungsdienstleister und die Aufarbeitung dafür übernimmt.
Und auf lange sich dann eben auch in die Spenderinnenverwaltung einsteigt.
Buchhaltung. Geil.
Siehst du mal, Tim, ich habe auch gedacht, wenn du nochmal Lust hast auf ein.
Wenn das mal nichts wird mit mit Podcasting irgendwie, wenn es dann habe ich immer noch äh noch eine Exit-Strategie.
Um das kurz noch zu sagen,
ne? Es handelt sich dabei um zwei Stellen, ne, also nicht beides zusammen, sondern es gibt zwei Stellen, also einmal diese äh äh Finanzengeschichte und einmal die IT-Geschichte und ähm ja, Link findet ihr in den Bewerbungsfristende
ist äh Bewerbungsfrist endet Ende Mai. Und äh ja, vielleicht ist das ja was für euch ähm.
Wie ihr euch dort bewerbt, findet ihr eben auf Netzbild org, Link dazu in den Shownotes, könnt ihr einen freundlichen Gruß da lassen.
Gut, die Redefrist für diesen Podcast endet jetzt. Damit haben wir irgendwie die Woche erstmal eingetütet, denke ich, oder?
Ja, also äh genau, denke schon. Ähm IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und Tickermock machen wir dann in der nächsten Sendung.
Machen wir in der nächsten Sendung, genau. Jetzt müssen wir uns noch ein paar andere Sachen kümmern.
Na schön, dann bleibt uns nicht äh viel anderes übrig, als euch noch eine angenehme äh Restwoche in der Restintelligenz zu wünschen. Lasst euch nicht äh lasst euch nicht äh verrückt machen.
Außer von uns natürlich.
Jo, alles klar. Ciao, ciao.